thierry bien ce qui nous a rejoint
bonjour gauthier et d'après les chiffres
officiels ukrainien 70% des hommes
ukrainiens ont contacté un centre de
renseignement pour faire partie de ces
volontaires c'est dire l'importance et
la mobilisation en ukraine aujourd'hui
oui importance de la mobilisation pas
importance de la frange ultra
nationalistes oui l'importance de la
mobilisation ça veut dire que
au cas où on aurait douté comme l'a fait
vladimir poutine de la réalité d'une
nation ukrainienne elle est
définitivement assises et est confirmée
par ce qui se passe c'est à dire que
dans dance et volontaire vous avez aussi
des personnes qui sont russophones
mais qu'ils se sentent avant tout une
crânienne et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on voit tout l'inanité la
vacuité de la théorie poutinienne qui
est nico linguistique autrement dit si
vous êtes russophone vous êtes du côté
des russes et si vous êtes ukrainophones
non ça marche pas comme ça et la
détermination dans les deux sens du
terme des personnes qui s'engagent dans
les dents les venues les unités de
volontaires pour assister l'armée
ukrainienne signifie bien qu'il y a une
identité ukrainienne et qui surpasse qui
dépassent des clivages qui serait
ethnique ou linguistiques un mot donc
sûr d'être sur ses bataillons
ultranationaliste on les a vu aussi dans
le reportage est ce qu'ils ont vraiment
des liens avec les nazis comme le dit
poutine alors d'abord permettez moi de
faire une remarque préliminaire sur ce
reportage lui-même qui est un excellent
reportage ça veut dire que à france24
télévision française occidental on est
capable de montrer des reportages qui
effectivement peuvent jeter un doute sur
la nature d'une certaine distance
ukrainienne vous ne trouverez jamais de
reportages sur les réseaux d'influencé
où les chaînes russes concernant par
exemple les milices ultranationaliste du
donbass et qui travaille auprès de
l'armée russe promis parenthèse fermée
ou alors sur leur importance c'est une
importance et on l'a vu dans le
reportage il s'agit de mini ce qui
s'inspire de losne au ou n
en alphabet cyrillique ce sont des
milices qui ont effectivement été très
active dans les années 40 et surtout à
partir de l'invasion de l'union
sovétique par les troupes hitlériennes
et qui ont prêté main forte à hitler
notamment dans la répression vis-à-vis
des résistants ukrainien des juifs
qu'ils soient ukrainiens ou polonais des
tziganes des homosexuels c'est à dire
bref toute la panoplie si vous me passez
le mot de la répression hitlériennes
effectivement ils ont prêté main forte
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'ils valent
aujourd'hui c'est une frange extrêmement
limités dont certains ont été incorporés
à l'armée ukrainienne pour être
dépouillé justement de leur de leurs
oripeaux 1-1 nazifiant en baptisant et
qui sont donc dans l'armée ukrainienne
est ce que ce que l'on vient de voir on
vraiment pignon sur rue disons
simplement que dans une guerre il ya
toujours la résurgence de telles
associations de tels organismes qui sont
effectivement non pas à la pointe du
combat mais qui essaye de tirer les
marrons du feu donc il existe simplement
il existe beaucoup moins qu'en 2014
lorsqu'il était très actif à maidan
parce qu'il y avait une démocratisation
la société ukrainienne et il existe
j'allais dire d'autant moins que hills
contre le phantasme de vladimir poutine
je veux dire par là que quand vous dites
que vous répéter à longueur de journée
qu'il y à des nazis en ukraine ça finit
par finalement être une prédiction auto
réalisatrice c'est à dire qu'on
rencontre effectivement des nazis donc
encore une fois ça n'est pas à négliger
mais ça n'est pas non plus la réalité de
la delà de la résistance ukrainienne et
même de la vie politique ukrainienne
j'en veux pour preuve le fait que la
dîme est rennaise qui faut-il le
rappeler est juif lui-même et qu'il
avait quand il a été élu en 2019
décréter que la fête juive de rosh
hashana ce serait une fête ukrainienne
une fête nationale ce qui était le cas
pendant un certain temps donc vous voyez
bien que cette histoire de des nazis
fier l'ukraine est non seulement un
cynisme mais aussi à partir du moment où
les russes y croit c'est une manière de
se dédouaner eux toujours de ce qu'ils
peuvent faire analogue à des pratiques
nazies étant donné que revendique
historiquement la victoire contre le
nazisme ce qui est réel mais aujourd'hui
les choses ne sont plus du tout comme ça
et lui l'un des problèmes de l'histoire
russe s'est effectivement de considérer
les choses comme figé telle qu'elle
l'était il y à 70 77 ans et de ne plus
savoir que l'histoire a bougé de
précisément c'est à la fois un moyen de
propagande c'est un moyen cynique et
c'est probablement une croyance
fallacieuse une croyance erronée merci
beaucoup gauthier rester avec nous a
écoutés